who hit you the hardest do you know
Dolph lunger put me in the hospital for
4 and 1/2 days it was unbelievable it it
was an accident that went forget what
we've been practicing now try to clock
me and I'll do my first best to defend
myself he pulverized me and that's
what's in the original
movie it was an uppercut caught the ribs
which hit the the heart against the rib
cage I didn't feel it at the moment but
later that night my heart started to
swell and then my blood pressure went up
to 260 the next thing I know I was on a
low altitude flight to intensive care at
St John's Hospital surrounded by four
nuns I thought here I go the end right
there yeah he said you usually get this
and head on collusions I said well close